this time let's put in an actual
triangle and I said three four five
before so let's just draw that guy
because he's pretty easy to draw three
four now we know enough to work out I'm
doing angles at the women okay so if you
haven't already because we have said
we're intrigued in a moment get your
calculator out and you see how I mug
this boy with a gross feet up before
okay now that I know what these sides
are I can actually work out the size of
this angle okay
there's lots of different ways to do it
because I have all three sides I can use
sine or cosine what time I want you to
pick any one you like and just tell me
what the size of this angle is or write
it on your page to the nearest degree
that'll do Neru
you're gonna need that table and this
chair don't say it yet but who's got an
angle for that who's gonna sighs yep
okay good so let's see it's Ivan right
Levin white ain't good you get nearest
agreement 36 is that match yeah 36 37
degrees if you did you mind
yeah okay so we're gonna get 37 right
watch out for that man why do we just
make a point on that right what do you
actually get as your decimal 36 point 36
point it's a Cooley that's rounding up
yeah okay see your face seven there it's
worth noting I did mention you can get
that 37 a variety of different ways
right
for instance I could say if I don't know
before I knew what the angle was would
just caught a field I could say well I
know for instance I know the opposite
and adjacent sides right I know the
opposite adjacent so I could have said
tan theta is equal to opposite adjacent
platform so I could purchase my
calculator theta equals 10 then minus
times they don't know the proper name of
that is 10 yeah that's very good
yeah 10 almost 10 inverse tan inverse
it's trying to do the opposite of tan
which is why it gets rid of the tail on
this side okay and I would've copy of 37
that's not the only way you could don't
though right if I come back two feet up
I can say I know the opposite and
hypotenuse so which ratio is that it's
time
so I coulda said sine theta is 3/5 so I
could have used sine inverse and I would
have gotten the same answer out okay all
right now that was just an aside we've
got 37 now okay this is a wide angle
triangle so that
so with that using trig anymore like
you've done enough tree
what's that angle up there it's going to
be what this Moses Plus this should give
me a 180 degrees right okay so if I'm
doing my numbers right that should be 53
53 okay now I've got a couple angles
there right now 3753 3753 they're
related to each other does anyone know
what the name is started to see the name
that relates those two together because
they add up to a million degrees they
don't oh that's cool they're called
complements okay so down for you I'm
gonna write 37 degrees and 53 degrees ah
you can see in a couple of ways you can
see they are complements or you can say
they're complementary angles and we mean
complementary with an e not like
complement is in nice haircut
but complement is in they go together
they match up their complementary angles
which means they add up now remember I
said to you okay I can look within this
triangle I know all the sides I know all
the angles so I can say a variety of
things about all the different trig
ratios so I'm still going over here you
don't make any any I know what theater
is right you told me it's 37 yeah and so
on
okay now here's what I want to focus on
this guy down here sign okay 3 over 5 3
over 5 from the point of view of this
angle over here I'm gonna put a little
man there right there's my point of view
my perspective okay from his perspective
this is officer on hypotenuse you agree
and that's why I use the sine you Tommy
you slow but 305 is another ratio it's
not opposite on hypotenuse if I'm
standing somewhere else if for instance
different color
I stand over here 305 is no longer
opposite on hypotenuse is it from that
point of view what is it yeah this three
is adjacent its its neighboring that
angle up there the man that's running
back 305 is adjacent over hypotenuse so
therefore I should be cosine right so
what statement could I write that
matches what you just told me you said
cause different point of view so it's
gonna be a different angle right 53 is
equal to that same three over five it's
the same thing okay so I'm gonna put
this in green if you got colors by the
way this is enormous leap up four so you
can see the parallels these two things
are the same side 37 and cos 53 okay now
this is not an accident and it's not
just a coincidence because of this
particular triangle that I made these
two angles tell me again how did you
work out this angle from this angle what
property did we use we use the earth we
use the angle sum of a triangle right
now every triangle shares that property
every triangle they all add at 180
degrees so if I had a triangle that's
maybe a bit smaller maybe I had a
smaller angle over here like 36 or 3418
that angle up there's gonna change but
it's still going to be complementary so
whatever's here in the corner you see
they're always going to add tonight so
the fact that these two are identical
therefore sine 37 this is not a
coincidence right in mathematics we're
always looking for patterns right this
is actually always going to be true
provided that these two angles are
complementary right so without drawing a
new triangle I could say sine 36 if I
make this angle a teeny bit smaller then
this angle will be a teeny bit bigger
right
they sort of have to match up together
they must add up to 90 degree
they must be complimentary okay it must
be complimentary and that's what the
courage stands for in cosine cosine
literally means it's the complement
complement this compliment of sine
okay let's generalize this this is just
for like two a week right but I can say
this from any angle
I can say sine of theta whatever theta
you like okay it's going to be equal to
now if I don't know what theater is how
am I gonna say what the complement of
theater is I don't know what its value
is
yeah very good the way I get 54 is it's
90 takeaway 36 the way out of this was
90 takeaway this so I'll say 90 take
away that now it doesn't take too much
to see for instance I started with sine
and then I noticed about Coast time but
I could have done it in Reverse right
compliments are a symmetrical
relationship right so to say 37 is the
complement of 53 is exactly the same as
saying the couplet of 53 is 37 so I can
say this the other way round as well I
can say cos theta will be sine of 90
minus theta okay put a box around it
because this this is the relationship
between sine and cosine cosine means
it's short for the compliment of side
whenever you discover the name of
something you've always got to push on
that a little bit you don't have to
necessarily understand why something is
named what it is but more often than not
something's name reveal to you something
fundamental about what something is
while I make that point we've done one
ratio two ratios there's a term ratio
you fit this way before haven't you
what's the tangent how are you a few
you've got a year's seven student
they've never seen this word before
right hands up if you don't have to set
hands up if you know what this word
means
your own idea okay let me draw it for
you
yeah circle is exactly right so your
circle okay and there's there's a
straight line I can draw that just
touches the circle just touches okay
which in fact by the way is where to a
tangent comes from is another word in
our language that we use when things
touch that starts the same way as they
will know when you say something is you
know you it's you can't put your hand
through it like air okay a table will
say it um we say it's tangible right you
can touch it a tangent is just touching
a circle now just a open thought for you
and we'll I'll give you the answer next
week I promise
this is a tangent tangent what on earth
does this have to do with this I don't
see any triangles in this diagram what's
up with that
okay mathematicians as you can see have
no problem making up new words for
things if we have a new idea right but
they chose to recycle this old word when
they were talking about something in
triangles
why did they do that well coordinator